these are the three most intense moments
in tigerbelly history starting off with
the time Bobby Lee invited his disgraced
Mentor Carlos Mania on the show for a
chance at Redemption all that other
believe that by the way I I believe that
as well and that's what stuck but the
thing that um is putting you in comedy
prison is the just the essence of the
stealing moment number two on this list
is the time Bobby Lee spilled the beans
to Bert Cher regarding Bert's agent
sabotaging comedians from joining his
Festival I may not I may not be able to
do this podcast after this why this is
cuz uh this specific one why this uh no
no let's change subject and the most
intense moment on this list comes to us
from episode 355 otherwise known as the
breakup of Bobby and Kila all right I
just want to announce to everybody that
Kila and I are no longer together